（コンコン）
はじめ）おはよーう
はじめ）おはよう
はじめ:心の声）俺の名前は江田川コナン
はじめ:心の声）特に身長が縮んだわけでもないけど探偵さ
はじめ）毛利おじさんおはよう
はじめ）起きて起きて
はじめ）もう会社の時間だよ
はじめ）毛利おじさん
はじめ）起きて毛利おじさんおはよう
トミック）おはよう
はじめ:心の声）そしてこいつは毛利のおっちゃん
はじめ:心の声）探偵だが…
はじめ:心の声）ただのおっちゃんだ
はじめ）おじさん今日も事件の匂いがするよ
、、、
はじめ）蘭ねぇちゃーーーーーん
はじめ）毛利おじさん起きて起きて
はじめ）早く探偵事務所に行こうよ
はじめ）おじさん早く行こ行こ
はじめ）探偵事務所に行こ、早く早くぅ
はじめ）おじさん早く探偵事務所行こうよ
はじめ）僕お暇
はじめ）何時だと思ってるの
はじめ）もう2時だよ
トミック）あ、ほんとだ
トミック）痛て
はじめ）おじさんお風呂に入る？
トミック）うん
はじめ）あれれ〜？
はじめ）事件の匂いがするなぁ
はじめ）おじさんお風呂に入って体を綺麗にしないとダメだよ
はじめ）おじさんコミュニティガイドラインのためにパンツを履いといてね
トミック）なに？
トミック）シャンプー？
はじめ）シャンプーです
トミック）めっちゃ寒いんですけど
トミック）閉めてー
はじめ）もうちょっとだけ我慢して
トミック）いや、めっちゃ寒いんですけど
トミック）閉めていいすか？
はじめ）ダメで(だ)よおじちゃん
トミック）洗顔は？
はじめ）洗顔あります
トミック）センキュー
トミック）あぁホイッププレミアムじゃん
トミック）うわぁ！うわぁ！うわぁ！
〜コナンの曲〜
はじめ）はははははｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）ははははｗｗ
トミック）ああ
はじめ）あ？え？ちょっと待ってｗ
はじめ）ははははｗｗｗはははははははｗｗｗ
はじめ）おじちゃんどうしたの？
トミック）事件だ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング　コナンVer.】
トミック）え、どうやってやったのこれ　すごくない
はじめ）大丈夫？